I want to talk to you about my kids now
I know everyone thinks that their kids
is the most fantastic the most beautiful
kid that ever lived but mine really are
I have six hundred and ninety-six kids
and they are the most intelligent
inventive innovative brilliant and
powerful kids that you'll ever meet any
student I'd have the honour of teaching
in my classroom is my kid however
because their real parents are rich and
I argue because they are mostly of color
they will seldom get to see in
themselves the awesomeness that I see in
them because what I see in them is
myself or what would have been myself I
am the daughter of two hard-working
college-educated african-american
parents who chose careers as public
servants my father a minister my mother
an educator wealth was never the primary
ambition in our house because of this
lack of wealth we lived in a
neighborhood that lacked wealth and
henceforth a school system that lap 12
luckily however we struck the
educational jackpot in a voluntary
desegregation program that buses
inner-city kids black and brown out to
suburban schools rich and white at five
years old I had to take an hour-long bus
ride to a faraway place to get a better
education at five years old I thought
everyone had a life just like mine I
thought everyone went to school and were
the only ones using the brown crayons to
color in their family portraits while
everyone else we're using the peach
colored ones at five years old I thought
everyone was just like me but as I got
older I started noticing things like how
come my neighborhood friends don't have
to wake up at five o'clock in the
morning and go to a school
an hour away how come I'm willing to
play the violin while my neighborhood
friends don't even have a music class
while my neighborhood friends learning
and reading material that I had done two
to three years prior see as I got older
I started to have this unlawful feeling
in my belly like I was doing something
that I wasn't supposed to be doing
taking something that wasn't mine
receiving a gift but with someone else's
name on it
all these amazing things that I was
being exposed to and experiencing I felt
I wasn't really supposed to have I
wasn't supposed to have a library fully
equipped athletic facilities or safe
fields to play in I wasn't supposed to
have theater departments with seasonal
plays and concerts digital visual
Performing Arts I wasn't supposed to
have fully resource biology or chemistry
labs school buses that brought me
door-to-door freshly prepared school
lunches or even air-conditioning these
are things my kids don't get you see as
I got older while I was grateful for
this amazing opportunity that I was
being given there was this ever-present
pang of but what about everyone else
there are thousands of other kids just
like me who deserve this - why doesn't
everyone get this why is a high quality
education only exclusive to the rich it
was like I had some sort of survivor's
remorse all of my neighborhood friends
were experiencing an educational train
wreck that I was saved from through a
bus ride I was like an education of
Moses screaming let my people go to high
quality schools I'd seen firsthand how
the other half was being treated and
educated I'd seen the educational
promised land and I could not for the
life of me justify the disparity I now
teach in the very same
whole system from which I sought refuge
I know firsthand the tools that were
given to me as a student and now as a
teacher I don't have access to those
same tools to give to my students there
have been countless nights when I've
cried in frustration anger and sorrow
because I can't teach my kids the way
that I was taught because I don't have
access to the same resources or tools
that were used to teach me my kids
deserve so much better we sit and we
keep banging our heads against this term
achievement gap achievement gap is it
really that hard to understand why these
kids perform well and these kids don't I
mean really I think we've got it all
wrong I think we as Gloria
ladson-billings says should flip our
paradigm and our language and call it
what it really is it's not an
achievement gap it's an education debt
for all of the for gone schooling
resources that were never invested in
the education of the black and brown
child over time a little-known secret in
American history that the only American
institution created specifically for
people of color the American slave trade
and someone argued the prison system but
that's another topic for another TED
talk the public school system of this
country was built bought and paid for
using commerce generated from the slave
trade and slave labor while African
Americans were enslaved and prohibited
from schooling their labor established
the very institution from which they
were excluded ever since then every
court case educational policy reform has
been an attempt to retrofit the design
rather than just stopping and
acknowledging we've had it all wrong
from the beginning an oversimplification
of American educational history
all right just bear with me blacks were
kept out you know mostly
with the help of philanthropic white
people they built their own schools
separate-but-equal was okay but while we
all know things were indeed separate
they were in no ways equal enter Brown
versus the Board of Education of Topeka
Kansas in 1954 legal separation of the
races is now illegal but very few people
pay attention to all of the court cases
since then that have undone the
educational promised land for every
child that Brown versus Board intended
some argue that today our schools are
now more segregated than they ever were
before we try to desegregate them in the
first place
teaching my kids about desegregation the
Little Rock Nine the civil rights
movement is a real awkward moment in my
classroom when I have to hear the voice
of a child ask if schools were
desegregated in 1954 how come there are
no white kids here these kids aren't
dumb I know exactly what's happening and
what's not they know that when it comes
to schooling black lives don't matter
and they never have for years I tried
desperately to cultivate in my kids a
love of reading I had a master montes
classroom library of books I'd
accumulated from second-hand shops
thrift stores attics you know but
whenever I said those dreadful words
take out a book and read you'd think I
just declared war it was torture one day
after I heard about this website called
DonorsChoose where classroom teachers
create wish lists of items they need for
the classroom and anonymous donors
fulfill them I figured I'd go out on a
limb and just make a wish list of the
teenagers dream library over 200
brand-new books were sent to my room
piece by piece every day there were new
deliveries and my kids would
exclaiming with glee this feels like
Christmas then they'd say mister where
these books come from and then I reply
strangers from all over the country
wanted you to have these and then they'd
say almost suspiciously but they're
brand new to which I reply you deserve
brand-new books the whole experience hit
home for me when one of my girls
actually peeled open a crisp paperback
said miss Sumner you know I figured you
bought these books cuz your teachers are
always buy enough stuff but to know that
a stranger someone I don't even know
cares this much about me it's pretty
cool
knowing that strangers will take care of
you is a privilege my kids aren't
afforded ever since the donation there
has been a steady stream of kids signing
out books to take home and then
returning them with the exclamation this
one was good
now when I say take out a book and read
kids rush to my library
I wasn't that they didn't want to read
but instead they gladly read if the
resources were there institutionally
speaking our public school system has
never done right by the black and brown
child we keep focusing on the end
results or test results and getting
frustrated we get to a catastrophe and
we wonder how did it get so bad how did
we get here really if you neglect a
child long enough you no longer have the
right to be surprised when things don't
turn out well stop being perplexed or
confused or befuddled by the achievement
gap the income gap the incarceration
rates or whatever socio-economic
disparity is the new it term for the
moment the problems we have as a country
are the problems we created as a country
the quality of your education is
directly
portion it to your access to college
your access to jobs your access to the
future until we live in a world where
every kid can get a high quality
education no matter where they live or
the color of their skin there are things
we can do on a macro level school
funding should not be decided by
property taxes or some funky economic
equation where rich kids continue to
benefit from state aid while poor kids
are continuously having food and
resources taken from their mouths
governor's senators mayors City Council
members if we're going to call public
education public education and it should
be just that otherwise we should call it
what it really is
poverty insurance public education
keeping poor kids poor since nineteen
fifty four if we really as a country
believe that education is the great
equalizer then it should be just that
equal and equitable until then there's
no democracy in our democratic education
on a meso level historically speaking
the education of the black and brown
child has always depended on the
philanthropy of others and unfortunately
today it still does if your son or
daughter or niece or nephew or neighbor
or little Timmy down the street goes to
an affluent school challenge your school
committee to adopt an impoverished
school or an impoverished classroom
close the divide by engaging in
communication and relationships that
matter when resources are shared they're
not divided they're multiplied and on a
micro level if you're a human being
donate time money resources
opportunities whatever is in your heart
there are websites like DonorsChoose
that recognize the disparity and
actually want to do something about it
what is a carpenter with no tools what
is an actress with no stage what is a
scientist with no laboratory what are
the doctor with no equipment I'll tell
you they're my kids shouldn't they be
your kids to thank
you